and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber the Lori valo
murder trial in Idaho took a break on
Monday as one of the attorneys Mourns
the loss of a family member so the
courtroom was dark for the whole day but
that doesn't mean we don't have a lot to
talk about with this trial so let's get
right into it Lori valo and her husband
Chad day Bell reportedly believed that
people had either light or dark souls
and that the darkest Souls could be
considered zombies so last week valo's
former best friend Melanie Gibb
testified that valo not only told her
that she believed her own children could
have dark spirits but that the she felt
called to get the dark Spirit out of
Tammy davil this is Chad dabell's wife
and within weeks of Tammy's death Chad
and Lori were married on a beach in
Hawaii her two children J.J valo and
Tyler Ryan had been missing for months
when the remains were later found on
dabel's property and according to the
medical examiner Tyler was dismembered
and burned JJ was bound with duct tape
and buried on Friday an interesting
witness took the Stan
was a friend of Lori and Chad's and even
married Lori's brother Alex Cox
unfortunately he died just two weeks
into their marriage the prosecutor asked
zulema about the group's beliefs and
things like past lives and evil spirits
as well as why she believed all of this
he told me that I had was
um I had been Laurie's daughter during
that probation or during that time that
I would learn that life that I had been
um
um killed at a very young age at age 14
that I had been
um
raped and then that my body had been
dismembered
by the limonites and I was killed at the
same time that
um Laurie was when she was my mother
during that life
Lori and Chad were very
um
aggressively
trying to convince me to move to Rexburg
and
um we talked a lot about him saying that
I needed to move to Rexburg why did they
want you to move to Rexburg
they kept telling me that part of my
mission was to be there and that I
needed to help them build cyan there and
that I just needed to move there Laurie
is
um very convincing
um
vivacious way of expressing things
um are very
charming and believing
plus the fact that
she had expressed before
that she had been visited by all these
Heavenly beings
therefore
if someone is telling the truth about
that
I wouldn't
I wouldn't be
questioning them I would be believing
they are telling the truth because I
would never think that someone would lie
about something as sacred as that
okay my co-hosts are here to break this
down defense attorney Brian buckmeyer
former trial Attorney Terry Austin Brian
so zilema gave the prosecution the
casting of dark spirits but also talked
about them making money off of the
children's Social Security and a call
where Lori was really mad before Tammy's
death is all of that enough to convict
Lori Jesse I've been pushing back on
this case saying I don't know if it's
all there yet or if there's a very there
to speak of but as you hear more and
more I think it's getting closer to
conviction the reason why I say that is
I don't think they're going to be able
to get the affirmative there was a a
plan or a conspiracy or or how exactly
Lori Aiden and embedded in the murder of
these two children and her husband's
ex-wife but I'm seeing less and less of
a reasonable doubt when you look at all
of these situations or surrounding them
and their belief of these spirits and
casting out put together
all right well I think we can agree
Terry zlim is a key prosecution witness
but she believed Lori followed her
instructions is she a credible witness
couldn't she be charged with a crime if
she's following everything she did you
know it's interesting she reminds me so
much of Melanie Gibb they both are
soft-spoken they both did whatever Chad
and Laurie said not to the extent that
Alex did but still they followed what
they were told and I think that at the
end of the day she's not going to have
anything that would implicate her in the
conspiracy or in the murders she didn't
Aid in a bet we haven't seen any
evidence to that effect just yet what
she is establishing though is the exact
same thing that Melanie established that
they were light and dark ratings and
that these ratings were put on other
people and that now these people are
gone so she's corroborating what Melanie
Gibb said and in a way this intoxicating
nature of this belief system and how
people were drawn in I think that's
clear as well still ahead a long crime
daily more peculiar testimony from
zelima pastennis as we continue our
cover
trial where she was working to cast out
dark Spirits did zulemma believe what
she was doing was hurting Tyler and JJ
her answer up next
foreign
triple murder trial in Idaho continues
now the so-called doomsday cult mom is
accused of being involved in the deaths
of two of her children Tyler Ryan and
J.J valo as well as her new husband's
wife now zulema pastennis who we talked
about earlier Lori's friend and one-time
sister-in-law testified about her
personal and spiritual experiences but
on cross-examination the defense asked
her about the idea of casting out dark
or evil spirits
you didn't think this was anything evil
or anything bad no okay
not at the time
but you've since then come to think that
it was evil or bad there are two
children that have died and a mother of
five that have died
I will consider that evil yes sir and
you believe that you were casting out
of spirits had some direct effect on two
children that died and the spouse of
another person that died
my belief is that
um I'm sorry that's just a yes or no
question
objection I asked it should be allowed
to answer
and I think that Council can handle that
on redirect
I agree it was just a leading yes or no
question so why don't you re-ask the
question Mr Thomas reckon I'm a support
reporter indicate what it was so uh to
my recollection what you're saying is
you believe that your
work on casting had a direct effect on
the two children that died and the
spouse of the person died that died
my work
Chad and Lori's work did all right
Terry what points do you think the
defense is trying to establish in that
cross-examination there I think several
points most of his across was very minor
though at that point he was trying to
say that the casting out did she really
believe that that worked did she think
that what she did affected the children
and I thought her answer was excellent
she said no I mean I believe in casting
out she later went on to say it's in the
Bible and I do believe in that and I
think he tried to make it look bad that
she had this belief I think that was a
mistake and she made it very clear that
she wasn't planning on any deaths that
that was Lori and Chad and she later
stated that that is what is evil so I
thought she did a very good job on cross
the minor points he made were you know
you came back after lunch and you knew
more then and were you looking at
documents those are all minor points and
it could backfire against him she's a
soft-spoken woman he's a male he's
cross-examining her and the jury could
look at that as if to say you are being
too brutal on her so I don't think he
made many points at all on that Crossing
Brian the other way look at it is what
makes her credible if she's believing in
these outlandish things I think Jesse is
about credible for what purpose do I am
I going to go to a Bible study with her
probably not I her version of of
religion is a little far off I think
most people but if we're talking about
the outlandish and the crazy and this is
an expert who is guiding us through that
world it's exactly like if a a sister
wife who had been trafficked got out of
that environment and is telling us about
it now he would say yes you were trapped
in a crazy situation but if you're
leading us down this path to explore and
teach us more I think for that purpose
she is credible and gives the
prosecution a lot to work with in terms
of the motive of both Lori and Chad Dabo
I think I just want to highlight one
more thing and that is that by all
accounts this jury this isn't the first
time they're hearing about all of this
okay we've been studying this for a long
time imagine being them and being
inundated with all of these stories and
characters
unbelievable